hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from chess comm Spock champs
championship it's its tournament where
popular streamers from different areas
will compete for a prize fund of $50,000
and they will play not one of the games
where they are wood they are usually
playing but they will play chess now
it's very it's a very interesting
concept and III do believe that it will
bring a lot of spotlight for chess I've
seen yesterday the will not not one
stream but different streamers that were
streaming chess regarding the POC Chess
Championship had almost 100,000 live
viewers maybe if you combine all of them
maybe even more so that's really insane
and it's very nice to see that chess is
doing so well that in 2020 now I know
voyboy as I was a I've played a lot of
League when I was younger maybe some 5
years ago maybe even 7 when when it may
be through season so maybe season 3 -
season 5 so I've seen a lot of his
streams and a lot of his videos and
that's why I chose this game and I'm not
much of a fortnight player I've only
played the one fortnight game in my life
so I don't know Nate Hill but as I
understand it he's a very very
accomplished and very popular in the
fortnight community as a professional
gamer also in this as a streamer and
he's also well known for his guitar
skills and singing as he he did a lot of
covers of popular songs before
committing a full-time - fortnight so as
a lot of you guys have requested for
some of the games for from pogchamp
championship but this is the one i chose
but you were more than welcome to
suggest some other end i will cover them
as well
now without further ado let's check it
out so Nate opens with efore and the boy
boy goes for the sicilian defence he
goes for c5 we have nine to three nights
the c6 and not now not the immediate
district in the center which you would
expect or some Bishop to b5 action but
Bishop the c4
so immediately putting pressure on f7
and usually black will deal with this by
going east 6 but avoidable goes for the
second popular or second most popular
option which is d6 we have castles by
Nate so he finished development a very
principled he got
night leadership into the game made the
room for the king at the castle and he
castles Verburg continues development we
have Knight to f6 next he's gonna go g6
Bishop g7 Castle kingside and so on so
the knight is the pawn is also under
attack so d3 a white defends it and now
g6 what would prepares the feeling here
to his dark square Bishop and Knight to
c3 nicely continuing development with
Bishop to g7 and now a normal move here
would be something like h3 and it is in
fact the most popular move here now the
problem is you've already developed the
bishop and close to the pawn chain here
and Bishop to g4 is definitely a threat
if Bishop g4 is combined with Knight to
d4 it will put a White's position into
some some trouble so here quinta ytube
by nate now this is a new move in the
position and already as a move 7 we have
a completely new game now the reason why
we have a completely new game is because
white did not prevent the Bishop to g4
and now this is a big problem and avoid
boy immediately takes advantage of this
so he goes Bishop to g4 and now of
course the threat is just nice to the d4
and it will be problematic now you don't
have time for h3 now because still
Knights the d4 attacks the Queen and you
cannot capture because of the pin here
so you'd have to move and then captures
with check captures and captures just
completely annihilates White's defenses
and the black will be a lot better here
so after Bishop g4 nade goes for Bishop
to e3 he guards the d4 square doesn't
allow the Knights to jump in and avoid
castles here so castles now castles and
here we have Bishop to b5 now trying to
get rid of this Knight not allow allow
him any jumps in the future however
Knight the e5 will still be dangerous
here as it comes away to the same idea
just Knight captures with Czech whoop
story
knife captors would to check and after
Jeep on recaptures you're gonna go
Bishop to h3 still but ok after there
should be 5 boy boy goes for Queen to b6
now he puts pressure on the bishop here
and also is ready to maybe recapture
with the Queen if this happens but a for
defending the bishop on
more time and also preparing a five so
we have a six attacking the bishop and
now we reach the position from the
thumbnail we have a five and it's a it's
a pawn sacrifice that this Lodge is the
night from his comfortable square on c6
however it's not all that easy to find
compensation for such a sacrifice avoid
boy does grab the pawn he goes for
Knight characters on a5 and now we have
Knight to d5 by Nate and it's a it's an
interesting move it probably comes with
the idea that maybe if Queen captures
here then maybe nice to see seven could
go for a double attack attacking the
Queen and the rook however you will
still give two pieces for the rook so
it's not all that great but the void boy
doesn't even go for this he just grabs
the night and there the bishop remains
undefended so he grabs a full piece here
so Knight character Sun d5 we have it
captures and now just the Queen captures
on b5 so now black wins a piece and now
it be well it'd be great
okay c4 was played he kicks back the
Queen the Queen still needs to keep an
eye on the night so it's not as harmless
but after Queen to b6 white no longer
has any means of recapturing the piece
if this rook was on b1 and if you could
go for something like b4 then you could
win back your piece because the knight
wouldn't have anywhere to go and it's
impossible to capture due to this pin
however you don't have it and well
there's just no good way to grab grab
bagg the piece so here Queen to d2 with
a double attack on the night but the B 3
square is available to the knight so
nice to be three and now there is a
double attack on the Queen and on the
rooks own it has to go back Queen d1 and
now a boy just grabs the exchange so
Knight captures rook Queen captures and
they want and now even Queen captures
and b2 offers to go into an endgame as
he's up material so Queen captures with
Bishop captures and now Knights the d2
not not going for any further trades as
Black is just up a full rook so b5 boy
boy wants to create a passed pawn and
when the game as soon as possible we
have C captures a captures the past
phone has been created and looked the b1
now hoping that after the bishop moves
you can maybe grab the b5 pawn but
whoever finds rook to a1 forces another
trade black is up a rook so every trade
is favorable only for black so row
capture sunny one Bishop captures in the
now tonight's the b3 going after the
bishop here but rook the a8 now nicely
defending we have h3 kicking away the
bishop and Bishop the f5 so White's
position is completely lost here as he
still down the rook and the void boy
still has his past beep on so Bishop to
g5 are going after the e7 pawn but
kinker faith will go nicely defended we
have King to h2 and now Bishop captures
on d3 grabbing yet another pawn we have
came to g3 white starts bringing the
King into the game but it is much too
late as white is still down a full rook
so rook to a3 putting pressure on the
night and now you have to capture so
character Sunday one root characters and
now King to f4 white can still hope to
maybe block off the position and maybe
maybe grab a stalemate however it is
easier said than done
avoid boy starts pushing his past pawn
we have before King the e3 and now
Bishop to f5 just getting the bishop out
of harm's way
the bishop also guards the queening
square so it's not a problem you don't
even need the rook here King F for white
brings the king of the board but now b3
with the trip to h6 check but it's not
not anything for for black to worry
about we have G for attacking the bishop
and Bishop back to d3 King III attacking
it again but now rook to d1 and now you
can no longer approach the bishop or the
rook so King of 3 but now beat you
bringing the Queen into the game h4 and
now finally be one black promotes the
pawn to a queen we have h 5 but now
Bishop the e4 check and the King hunt
begins with King to f4 and now rook to F
1 preparing the capture on f2 h captures
on g6
there is nothing better pretty much or
whatever you do you get checkmated so
rook captures an f2 King g5 and now
Queen the c1 with
doesn't really matter where the King
goes if King to h5 then just work to h2
is checkmate
so King the h4 was played but now Queen
to h1 with check King to g5 and now of
course you will see mate in one this is
one of the one of the few occasions
where it is actually okay to play f6 and
here what we played f6 and well it's
just checkmate now as the King has
nowhere to go so if it's if f6 delivers
checkmate then it is okay to play of 6
so it was it was a very interesting game
by both of them and at some point and it
just lost the the threat of the game and
after this a5 which is interesting there
are of course openings and positions
where they spawn is sacrificed to
dislodge denied however this wasn't one
of them and then Knight to d5 was just
was just too much probably probably he
was going for this idea that I mentioned
but it's hard hard to say so now a good
game was better and it's a well-deserved
win so these are some of the some of the
players that will be competing in this
portion championship so whoops
sorry about that let me just let me just
load that ok here it is these are some
of the streamers that will be competing
so here they are so you know what's
what's happening so there we have it we
have a void boy
firstly nade he'll Europe be two to one
hutch moist critical yeah so and xqc
we've already checked out one game
between xqc and nakamura so even for
those of you who are not in the gaming
community you have already met him yeah
if you enjoyed it doot-doot-doot suggest
some other games maybe of your favorite
streamers and we're gonna check out
those games as well so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank triangle bill for francesco de
Bertolli robert Holtzman Bradley
Schneider and Stephen koepfer for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of
pretty much everything that's going on
in the world today checking up on your
wonderful suggestions continuing the
Morpheus
and so on so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your weekend